il y en a assez de se la jouer chacun
pour soi chacun de son côté
la mutuelle des ménages prévoyante ce
sont des êtres humains et vous avant
tout en cas d'urgence vous pouvez
contacter notre assistance 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7
parce que votre santé n'attend pas une
mutuelle qui répond toujours présent
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
cliquez et vérifier le dès maintenant
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
check up votre émission santé et
bien-être
au programme dans ce numéro des sessions
gratuites de formation aux gestes qui
sauvent sont organisées dès le 1er
février dans toutes les églises une
opération pilotée par la préfecture et
les acteurs du secours
nous vous ferons ensuite découvrir les
fleurs de bach ces élixirs destinée à
apaiser et améliorer vos émotions vous
aurez également l'occasion de découvrir
la pratique de la sono thérapie ou
l'utilisation des sons pour harmoniser
le corps et l'esprit
et pour terminer focus sur l'hypnose une
pratique de plus en plus utilisés
aujourd'hui notamment dans le soin d
addiction
mais pour commencer le mercredi 20
janvier le réseau de surveillance
sentinelles composé de 1300 médecins
généralistes libéraux annoncé que le
seuil épidémique de la gastro entérite
étaient atteints en france
métropolitaine
ce seuil est atteint lorsque 193
personnes sont malades pour 100000
habitants la semaine dernière la france
étaient encore concernés puisqu'il y
avait 247 cas pour 100000 habitants
le docteur flory médecins à coignières
nous en explique les raisons
la première manière de s'en prémunir
c'est justement une des mesures de
protection par rapport à ça des mesures
d'hygiène celmo cardinal par rapport à
la gastro et dans la toute première
mesure pour s'en protéger
c'est tout banalement le lavage des
mains de lavage bien bien soigneux le
brassage des ongles etc
le virus ça s'appelle à rotavirus ces
temps de crise assez banal et donc
métier très résistant et donc ils
résistent assez facilement à l'extérieur
de l'organisme et donc il a le temps de
se transmettre
après les attentats de 2015 de nombreux
français ont exprimé le souhait de
connaître les gestes utiles pour sauver
des vies en réponse à cette demande le
ministère de l'intérieur en partenariat
avec la préfecture et l'ensemble des
services de secours vont organiser dès
le mois de février
des séances d'initiation gratuite aux
gestes qui sauvent dans les yvelines à
l'issue de chaque session les
participants se verront remettre une
attestation reportage alerter masser
défibriller posé un garrot et traiter
les hémorragies
ces gestes qui peuvent paraître
complexes au premier abord seront
dispensés au cours de sessions de
formation gratuite sur tout le
territoire yvelinois dès le 1er février
3 que c'était très important que nos
concitoyens prennent conscience qu'ils
peuvent être acteurs acteurs de la à la
fois de leur propre sécurité et de la
sécurité de leurs concitoyens s'ils sont
confrontés à une situation de crise
ces cessions qui seront pilotées par la
croix rouge et le sdiss ne se substitue
pas à la formation de premiers secours
que le participant peut toujours suivre
par la suite pour élargir ses
connaissances
de plus en plus de personnes souhaitent
acquérir les bons réflexes en cas de
situations notamment sévères comme
l'arrêt cardiaque et bien entendu par
exemple des hémorragies ou des plaies
importantes en partenariat avec
l'éducation nationale 3 lycées ont été
sélectionnés pour dispenser ces
formations dont un à montigny le
bretonneux
je rappelle que ce sont des actions qui
ont lieu le samedi matin donc ça suppose
que les établissements soit ouvert mais
on pourra élargir puisqu'il s'agit aussi
d'un engagement volontaire de la part
des adultes et et des élèves que ces
établissements recrutent au delà bien
entendu de leur propre public scolaire
pour les inscriptions sur les cessions
gratuites rendez vous sur le site de la
préfecture
sur le mois de février ce sont 80 cette
session qui sont programmés dans le
département
dimanche 24 février à voisins le
bretonneux l'association voisins adultes
relais organisé son deuxième salon dédié
au bien-être sur le thème de l'art de
vivre et de l'épanouissement personnel
ce salon proposait aux participants de
découvrir les médecines douces et
alternative par le biais de conférences
et d'ateliers chromothérapie sono
thérapie shiatsu ou encore relaxation
par lâcher prise
voilà un aperçu des différentes
pratiques que l'on pouvait découvrir
samedi dernier à voisins le bretonneux
au salon du bien-être conférences et
démonstrations étaient proposées toute
la journée pour s'initier à ces méthodes
peu conventionnelles
il ya une mode c'est sûr qu'à une mode
et justement la vie étant stressante
actuellement pour que les grands comme
pour les petits d'adhésion de vulgariser
entre guillemets ces méthodes ça aide
les personnes qui peuvent en avoir
besoin de les trouver à proximité des
intervenants yvelinois comme fabienne
qui présentait son livre au public un
travail basé sur l'harmonie des émotions
grâce au coaching en images aux cristaux
et aux fleurs de bach ont dîné lors des
vagues puisque le dr bach on avait
découvert 38
des fleurs qui ont des vertus or et
harmonisent ans qui vont au calme et qui
vont nous permettre de produire près par
avoir une situation pour les matières
qui vont nous permettre de reprendre le
moral un élixir qui contient l'essence
de la fleur que fabienne prescrit à ses
patients après consultation la personne
va me va me parler de ses émotions du
moment de ses ressentis de ce qu'elle
ressent de ce qu'elle vit de ses peines
de ses colères de tout ce qu'elle peut
ressentir et au travers de 7 700 ce
panel je dirais de l'émotion eh bien on
va décider ensemble ça j'insiste là
dessus du cocktail de fleurs que l'on va
mettre dans son flacon une méthode
naturelle qui séduit de plus en plus
mais qui ne se substitue pas des soins
classiques
chaque année dans le monde ce sont
plusieurs dizaines de millions de fioles
de fleurs de bach qui s'écoule c'est une
méthode de plus en plus répandue se
décline désormais de bien des manières
notamment dans le milieu médical
l'hypnose cette pratique qui permet de
modifier l'état de conscience d'un
individu est utilisé pour soigner des
addictions ou bien des douleurs
physiques à elancourt marilyn terré et
sophrologue et pratique l'hypnose en
cabinet nous avons suivi une de ces
séances nouveau plonger encore plus
profondément dans cet état
tout commence par l'induction à la
détente le ton est doux et monocorde
votre corps devient de plus en plus une
longue mise en condition de relâchement
pour atteindre l'état d'hypnose et
l'hypnose c'est ni plus ni moins qu'un
état de ce qu on appelle un état de
conscience modifiée donc un état qui
n'est mis la veille neil sommeil et
c'est un état en fait où notre
inconscient va être beaucoup plus
sensible et suggestive lé donc où les
suggestions qu'on va pouvoir faire vont
avoir plus du coup d'emprise l'objectif
de cette pratique
intégrer des suggestions dans l'esprit
du patient habits qu'elle souffre
d'insomnie et participe régulièrement à
ces séances
dans 30 minutes mariloup wolfe sur un
rythme régulier concentrer sur le poids
des mots on va faire attention par
exemple à ne pas utiliser de négation on
va toujours proposé des formulations
positive clair pour que le l'inconscient
puisse vraiment entendre et percevoir et
du coup intégré ces suggestions
la suggestion une fois intégré marie
been rappelle sa patiente
vous pouvez maintenant ouvrir les yeux
ou sont en salaire et qu'un la voie que
j'entends finalement c'est une voie qui
est dans ma tête qui me disent que je
dois faire comment me relaxer quand je
suis comme ça je me dis pas bon bah je
suis dans une salle il ya même un
thérapeute cayla et non c'est vraiment
dans la tati nanan d'impression c'est ça
réduire le stress ou encore arrêter de
fumer
la pratique de l'hypnose est de plus en
plus utilisée de nos jours également
entrer dans certains hôpitaux pour
remplacer des anesthésies générales
cette méthode reste non reconnue par
l'académie de médecine
c'est une médecine alternative qui
existe depuis le 16e siècle mais qui
reste encore aujourd'hui méconnu la sono
thérapie cette technique de bien-être
par massage sonore est une méthode de
soins censé équilibrer la circulation
d'énergie dans le corps nous avons
rencontré david baconnais sono
thérapeute à fontenay le fleury qui nous
a expliqué cette pratique
où
moi
reposant à l'ecoute se sont mené
pourtant pas destiné à vos oreilles mais
à votre cerveau et vos organes david
backes connaissons nos thérapeutes
il utilise les sous pour équilibrer la
circulation d'énergie dans le corps
c'est une technique qui aident à
retrouver l'équilibré pour une meilleure
santé morale une meilleure santé
physique tout le travail de la sono
thérapie se trouvait la vibration
approprié pour harmoniser les vibrations
pour qu'il n'y ait plus de 10 à rosny
pour retrouver l'équilibré
une méthode thérapeutique qui agit au
temps sur le psyché que sur le physique
pour soigner le stress par exemple david
eut glissé bol tibétain
ap les bols chantants on a tous une
énergie qu'on dégage d'une façon plus ou
moins large et donc les vols qui seront
sept métaux chacun des métaux va va
vibrer plus ou moins ce temps selon
l'état énergétique deux personnes moi
j'aime me résumer sans les ans selon les
creux et les bosses votre méthode
utilisée celle des diapasons ici david
parle de méridien comme une sorte
d'acupuncture sonore chaque note
correspond un point particulier musicien
qui a mis en place cette technique des
diapasons qui fait bien maman a trouvé
une note pour chaque déposant donc deux
même façon on la met en vibration et on
va le poser sur la main sur le point qui
est intéressant pour la personne
voilà la sensation que j'avais c'était à
la fois d'être pris en charge et en même
temps d'avoir vraiment une direction
chaque chaque son chaque sensation comme
ça à chaque son avait avait une vraie
volonté et ça ça m'a surpris en fait
même si la sono thérapie reste une
médecine douce non reconnue par
l'académie de médecine
plusieurs études ont déjà mis en avant
l' influence des sons et des fréquences
sur les organes passons maintenant à
l'agenda
tout d'abord rendez-vous à magny les
hameaux le samedi 6 février pour un
atelier autour du thème manger sain vous
apprendrez comment utiliser les graisses
dans votre assiette et aussi les
différents types de cuisson pour y
participer
réservé à l'adresse indiquée et puis
comme il était dit précédemment dans le
reportage je vous rappelle qu'il est
important de s'inscrire aux formations
des gestes qui sauvent 87 sessions sont
organisées tout le mois de février dans
le département yvelinois pour connaître
les dates et lieux et réservez votre
place
rendez vous sur le site de la préfecture
voilà check up c'est maintenant terminé
quant à moi je vous donne rendez-vous
dans deux semaines pour un prochain
numéro
et d'ici là prenez soin de vous